Got a lot of snow
to get rid of.
Time to get
a new outhouse built.
It's something I need right now.
This summer I went ahead and dug
a couple different holes
around the property,
but my wrist was broke
in an accident this fall.
I'm starting to recover finally
to where I can, you know,
start doing projects like this,
and now I gotta go dig out
all the blown-in, drifted snow
before I can get started.
♪
There we go,
I'm into the hole now,
there's the framing that I used
to shore up the sides,
that way
when the ground's thawed
it can't just slough in
and be filling up the hole.
This might not seem like
a very fancy bathroom,
but I look around and I think,
man, this is
the perfect setting.
Feel like you're out here
in the middle of nowhere.
It's nice, not too far a walk
from my place, but far enough,
you know, you don't want
to have your outhouse
too close to your house.
You don't want the smell,
you know,
although I'm gonna use some
sawdust to keep the smell down.
Let's talk about it like it is,
you know. Gotta poop.
[laughs]
♪
Alright, got this
nice and dug out here
and good little
workspace and area.
Next step, go get some
materials, start my build.
Hang on, bud.
♪
I'm gonna head down
into the woods here,
find a spot to get myself
all the posts and crosspieces
that I'm gonna need for
the structure of the outhouse.
♪
Oh, yeah, that's it right there.
Alright, this tree right here
is nice and dead.
It's got, uh, looks like all
the pieces that I'm gonna need.
You stay, Neil, you stay
right there. Good boy.
♪
This is what you call
my lumberyard right here.
Some people see
the disadvantages
of living out in the bush.
I look at the advantages of it.
If I need to go get
some wood to work with,
it's right here in my backyard.
♪
Alright!
The goal is just to make
a simple outhouse.
I'm just gonna use what I got
around me, spruce poles,
and I kinda like that look
aesthetically as well.
I've got all my pieces here
for my outhouse,
they were all in one tree,
that gave me a bunch
of firewood, too,
so, just couldn't get it
better than that.
Load up, Neil,
let's get out of here, buddy.